- [Voiceover] So Kim, in the last video
we started talking about how slavery
has been an issue in the United States
really since its founding
with the Revolutionary War.
And we see some images here of slavery.
This was a particularly famous image
that really kind of
helped spark indignation
in the North among Abolitionists
'cause you can see how this
person was beaten or whipped.
- [Voiceover] Yes absolutely.
- [Voiceover] So it's kind of, you know,
and today we all think it's
morally reprehensible thing
but you go back not too far
in the whole scope of history.
We're going to the early 1800s,
and this was something that was debated.
It was slavery was allowed
in a large chunk of the United States.
And in the last video, we talked about
that this issue of slavery
only got exacerbated
the more territory that was added.
You have the Louisiana Purchase in 1803
that adds all of this territory.
You start having states getting carved.
Once you get a critical population,
a critical mass of
people in a certain state
they can apply to be, or
in a certain territory,
they can apply to be a state.
And as each of these states are added,
and they want to get representation,
it's a political issue.
You mentioned how the
North, they didn't like it
on moral grounds and if
it was a slave state.
And they also didn't like
it on economic grounds
'cause it's hard to compete
economically with slavery.
While the South was afraid
of losing its political power
if more free states
were to join the Union.
And the Compromise of 1820, you mentioned
that well that compromise,
Missouri is a slave state.
Maine gets carved out of Massachusetts,
becomes a free state.
But that didn't solve the problem.
That problem only
continues because we only
add more territory.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I
mean most of the history
of the 1800s, when it comes to slavery,
is a history of putting off the problem.
Henry Clay becomes this
very famous legislator
because he's good at compromising.
He's called the "Great Compromiser".
So, instead of trying to actually solve
the issue of slavery, which many people
think of as an unsolvable problem.
They're just saying,
"All right, well how can
"we put off a conflict over
this a little bit longer?"
- [Voiceover] And they
just keep doing that.
You know, in 1836 the
territory expands further,
or it starts to I guess.
The expansion is catalyzed further
by you have the Texas Revolution.
Texas get its independence from Mexico.
Which itself got independence
only a few decades
before that from Spain.
But so Texas, for a brief amount of time,
is its own independent country.
But then, it joins the US,
it's annexed by the US in 1845.
So it's more territory for the US,
and that was slave territory.
- [Voiceover] Right, yeah so again,
this is an area in the South where
most of the reasons that
slavery existed in the South
is because it's a very fertile
agricultural region, right?
Where the things that you grow, crops,
are very labor-intensive.
So they figure, how are we going
to find enough people to grow these crops?
And the answer is that they've
been importing African slaves
and forcing them to work.
- [Voiceover] And the annexation of Texas,
there's war disputes with Mexico
which leads to even, another
conflict with Mexico.
This time with the US and Mexico.
This is the Mexican-American
War from 1846 to 1848.
But in the context of this conversation,
the reason why it helped
bring the slavery issue
even more to a head, is
that when the US wins it,
it gets even more territory.
It gets all of this area in
the West, right over here.
- [Voiceover] Right, it's more territory.
And it's more sort of Southern territory
which means that it has a high probability
of becoming slave states.
- [Voiceover] And so, this map that we
looked at earlier in the other video,
this is kind of showing
what the US looked like
as we exit out the Mexican-American War.
We're getting to about 1850.
And so, what happens then?
I mean, is it just one compromise
after another at this point?
- [Voiceover] Well, this is
the point where compromise
begins to break down.
Henry Clay again, is the architect
of what's called the Compromise of 1850.
As soon as the US goes to war with Mexico,
people in Congress are wondering,
"All right, if we get this territory
"that we're trying to get,
what's going to happen?
"Are they going to be free
states or slave states?"
And this compromise over
free and slave states
has been going on for 30 years
since the Missouri Compromise.
And even longer, if you
take it back to 1776.
So, they're doing exactly the same thing.
They're saying, "All right, well let's try
"to keep a balance of power
"between free states and slave states."
Except, they add in a couple of provises
that make people really
angry in the 1850s.
- [Voiceover] And who gets angry?
- [Voiceover] Both I
would say, slaveowners
and Abolitionists and anti-slavery
activists in the North.
- [Voiceover] So, I guess that's
what makes it a compromise.
A little something to
make everybody angry.
(laughter)
What made the slave owners angry
about the Compromise of 1850?
- [Voiceover] One of the parts
of the Compromise of 1850,
apart from deciding whether
these new territories
were going to be slave or free
was a part of the Act,
was called the Fugitive Slave Act.
And the Fugitive Slave
Act said that it was
a federal offense not
to help slave owners recover--
- [Voiceover] So this is
something the Abolitionists angry?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- [Voiceover] Or the anti-slavery angry?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, absolutely both.
So for example, if you're
maybe living in Massachusetts,
you're a white middle-class person
living in Massachusetts, you
don't think slavery is great.
You think it's morally wrong,
but it hasn't really directly
affected your life. Right?
You're hundreds of miles away
from the nearest slave state.
But now, the federal government says
that if there is a person
who has escaped from slavery
who has come to your town,
it is a federal offense
for you not to help
return that person to slavery.
- [Voiceover] So this Fugitive Slave,
this is part of the compromise?
This is part of the Compromise of 1850.
Is that I could be
sitting in Massachusetts,
I could be anti-slavery or I could even be
ambivalent about it.
But now, I have to be complicit in it.
If there's a slave, I can't.
Or if there's someone who's escapes
from the South who is a former slave,
I have to actively, I
can't in any way help them.
If I do, I could go to jail.
If I'm a law officer, I
have to capture that person,
and I have to bring them back.
So it's kind of forcing people who are
already not happy about slavery,
it's kind of bringing it close to them.
They have to partake in it.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and these are people
who have very strong
religious convictions.
This is the mid-19th century is a time
when people feel their
religion very strongly.
And so, there are people in
the North who are Quakers.
Who are otherwise religiously
opposed to slavery.
Who have maybe prayed
for the souls of slaves,
but it's never been their job
to try to keep someone in slavery before.
So that is really infuriating.
One of the things you get out this
is a really strong backlash
of Abolitionist sentiment
in the North.
For example, Harriet Beecher Stowe,
she's the daughter of a
reverend who's against slavery.
She writes the book Uncle Tom's Cabin
which becomes this smash hit.
- [Voiceover] And when was this roughly?
- [Voiceover] This was about 1852.
- [Voiceover] OK, so this is
after the Compromise of 1850.
So, people are getting, it
really is coming to a head.
The people in the North, they're having
to partake in this because
of the Fugitive Slave Act.
You have Harriet Beecher Stowe
writes Uncle Tom's Cabin.
It makes people even more upset
about the realities of slavery.
- [Voiceover] Right, and in the South,
they've kind of gotten away,
white slave owners in this time
with people saying, "Ya know,
"slavery's not really my problem.
"I don't like it."
But now they're seeing
a concentrated attack,
a moral and social attack
against slavery in the North.
And their response is to become even more
violently in favor of slavery.
They pose the idea that
slavery is not just something
that we could turn our eyes away from,
but it's necessary.
But it's a positive good.
Slavery is actually going to actually
make the country better.
If it weren't for slavery, all
of these enslaved Africans,
African-Americans, their lives
would be worse without us.
- [Voiceover] And so, just to be clear
on the Compromise of 1850.
And there was a bunch of things,
we went into a whole video
on the Compromise of 1850,
all of the different facets of it.
But it's one of its, in
terms of this conversation,
one of its outcomes is because
of the Fugitive Slave Law.
It infuriated many of the
anti-slavery Abolitionists
in the North.
They became more entrenched
in their positions
which made the Southerners more entrenched
in their positions.
The Southerners didn't necessarily,
they liked the Fugitive
Slave Law, the Southerners.
The Compromise of 1850 sounds like it was,
it was a compromise,
not everyone was happy.
But it sounds like it made
the anti-slavery folks more unhappy
than the slavery folks.
- [Voiceover] Yeah absolutely.
So it makes the anti-slavery
folks super unhappy,
but it also means that now
white slave owners in the South,
they feel like there's
a target on their heads.
And so, they're going
to dig in even further
to make sure that their interests
in slavery are protected.
- [Voiceover] And this gets
us to the election of 1860
which I guess in some ways was the straw
that breaks the camel's back,
I guess from a Southern perspective.
And why is that?
- [Voiceover] Well, during the 1850s,
you have all of these
political battles over slavery.
In fact, it kind of breaks
the major political party
of the 1850s, the Whig Party.
So, in 1860, some of these leftover Whigs,
they reorganize as the Republican Party.
And this is the first election
with a Republican Party
that we know today.
But obviously, in 1860, the things
that they're interested
in, their goals and aims
are completely different.
And the Republican Party
is an anti-slavery party.
They're deliberately and
publicly against slavery.
So, they nominate as their
political candidate for 1860,
Abraham Lincoln who is
well-known in the country
for having been an anti-slavery agitator.
He's given many speeches where he has
made very eloquent
arguments against slavery.
- [Voiceover] He's, we talked
about in the previous video,
he's against it, I guess on moral grounds.
But perhaps even more, his old father
wasn't able to be a successful farmer
because he had to compete
with slave owners.
- [Voiceover] Right, so he's
brought up to hate slavery
because it's a big
business that has harmed
his own family's economic future.
But, he comes, I think,
to his own conclusion
that slavery is morally wrong.
What he doesn't think that
he can do as president
is legally or constitutionally,
get rid of slavery.
He doesn't think that the
Constitution allows it.
But, he is seen as enough
of a threat by Southerners
that in many cases, on the
presidential ballots in 1860,
you couldn't even vote for Abraham Lincoln
if you wanted to.
He didn't show up on the
ballot in Southern states.
Nonetheless, he still gets
enough electoral votes
that he's elected.
- [Voiceover] And then
that's what takes us into
the real meat of, you know,
catalyzes the Civil War.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, stay
tuned, Abraham Lincoln.